[Music]
me and the writers we came up with a
fantastic new morning show and a very
unique way to shoot it that is pretty
inexpensive we are excited about this
new show take a look good morning
welcome to wake up and backup the only
show filmed entirely on the backup
camera of a Toyota Sienna it's a lot of
fun it keeps our blood flowing we love
it yeah it's a show on the go ha hey
before we get going too far Jenny how
was your weekend
oh yeah actually really amazing ok a
little hiccup there but hey it's our
first show and we have our first guest
and he's gonna teach us how to make
authentic New Orleans breeze from New
Orleans
okay now this fish stock should have
been in the oven for about a half-hour
this is a good point to start chopping
your salary we got a mince the garlic we
got
[Applause]
back home to me yep it's great at
parties and thanks for watching be sure
to join us next week when actor Sidney
Poitier sits down to discuss his
legendary acting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
got a few kinks to work out with that
show but I think it's gonna be amazing
we need to hire two more hopes we'll get
him